welcome to this video recording area a
bit a bit distorted maybe I can provide
a bit yeah so let's play against gender
gender from from the Netherlands Oh
fianchetto Kings Indian double of you in
chatham let's see okay but is going for
a d5 setup so maybe is more like a
growing fault person not with g6 but
with d5 okay yeah here nighty file is a
simple but good option opening up the
long diagonal and maybe allowing white
to put some pressure on the queenside
it's not so easy now for him to to
develop the bishop on c8 my white also
has an enum an extra porn in the center
i'm not going to even calculate the
exchanges why does wide to ski bum a
good position in any case here with
queen bee three maybe just queen bee
three
we should age three I can maybe play
clean b7 it's just um it's just often
the exchange but I don't really believe
that he has enough compensation but I
wonder if this is still the way to go
especially in a blitz game maybe this is
an idea trying to provoke that in trade
the whole structure is favorable for
wired so yeah here I thought that my
control will oversee for is quite nice
92 with this control over the sea
foursquare yeah but here I can can take
on f60 maybe get Knight to c4 against
this bishop who could be one okay can
play Bishop c3 look here I guess to
cover see form oh this is very very
helpful that he exchanged that now I get
the Knight to c4 and then at the end
that's a4 a5 with pressure against the
Queen Sonya this is a fantastic position
now a white fantastic is maybe a bit
much but it's it's like super one-sided
it's a very masochistic task ahead for
black
Roxy to Brooke a to Roxy one Roxy to a
five and at the end the be pawned will
be the problem very difficult for black
to defend okay I'm so is anticipating
this but you really has no great way out
ma six maybe no it's 6i can take brooke
a 7 p-1 k to be our chem
yeah at the very very one-sided end game
probably would be one hook a to a five
this should be the next move what you
really should have done you should have
avoided the bishop trade putting the
bishop back only six I think I think it
was possible all right so that Evan
night comes to see ye can just take it
yeah I guess he's seeing the problem now
or maybe I'm just talking he and I have
lost connection or something no or he
has lost connection no it's still quite
weird okay what he could try to defend
us of course Bishop d8 but then the
snotty 5c 6 also it's not very not very
nice
I don't get it maybe had a very someone
rang at the door or something that's a
shame I would have loved to play play
dissolved because it's fairly
instructive with a five and those things
coming Jim yeah so we'll upload this is
so because it's quite instructive to see
how this position would would continue
to be a played
black4 fits on time ya never know what
what happened them um yeah let's let's
have a look at this so whoopsie too and
yeah one problem is if black wants to
anticipate the a5 push they would be
here but 95 and 96 is a very very
annoying prospect so this is not on we
can try to check what the computer will
do to defend let's play out some
computer museum on stock fish place g5
next move would be rook be one king g7
rook a two would be my legs move now it
plays route d to be seven and a 5a 5b
takes rook takes yeah now we get this as
mentioned very favorable end game with
those two week oops sorry those two
weaknesses very am very very young
uncomfortable to defend this white can
even improve the position a bit G for
walking a 383 and then it's it's
question out to continue maybe maybe I
don't have from something better than
exchanging a versus B porn but still
this position would be am not much fun
to play if we if we get to this this
type of thing here three Bishop I don't
know maybe black should do this maybe I
should play g4 before but okay it's not
not that not that important it takes
takes I want to get to get to this
position I think here black is probably
you hear the worst is over I shouldn't
really allow black to play G form should
maybe play a play G form
self age 4 h3 keep this pawn on d5 maybe
I have king of three those kind of
things here here king of 3 III King into
it said i should i should play am i
should play this a bit slower just
doubling on a 7 and trade those two
pawns it's not leading to a win probably
maybe keeping the rooks then try a
dislike 92 e 4 that's impossible it's
it's a very one-sided position but still
nothing that what should be resigned or
anything okay thanks for watching